we are 720 days away from election day
2024 and for the last two years Donald
Trump has been claiming the 2020
election was stolen from him but the
former president is now officially ready
for 2024. last night he announced he is
running to get back into the White House
and he does it in the face of legal
troubles and after just a couple days
from a disastrous midterm where many of
the candidates he endorsed were defeated
or underperformed chief Washington
correspondent Major Garrett was at
Mar-A-Lago for the announcement and he
joins us now from Palm Beach major
you've seen a lot in politics but you've
never seen this good morning what was it
like in the room
well good morning Tony good morning
everyone the ballroom at Mar-A-Lago was
packed and the crowd was well dressed
because As Trump might say hey it's High
season here in Palm Beach
when he came out chance of USA USA USA
everything going according to script and
then Trump started speaking and
something was noticeable a lack of
energy and urgency
I am tonight announcing my candidacy for
president of the United States
in announcing his third bid for the
presidency Donald Trump tried in vain to
capture the spirit of his 2016 Insurgent
campaign we will be taking on the most
corrupt forces and entrenched interests
imaginable this is not a task for a
politician or a conventional candidate
Trump displayed a fraction of his 2016
energy the speech ran twice as long as
scheduled and for long stretches left
his crowd restless and Silent Trump
tried to boost Spirits by claiming
Republicans had won control of the house
something they appear poised to do in
the midterms my endorsement success rate
was
232 wins and only 22 losses Trump put
the best face on Republican midterm
failures and said he bore none of the
blame even though some of his
hand-picked candidates lost in key races
absent were recent Trump personal
attacks on Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
and Virginia governor Glenn Younkin this
is getting stale Sam nunberg is a former
Trump advisor who now backs DeSantis
that's the worst way you could ever
attack Donald Trump meanwhile DeSantis
fresh off a runaway re-election victory
was asked Tuesday about Trump's insults
I would just tell people to go check out
the scoreboard from last Tuesday night
Trump celebrated Administration
accomplishments on economic growth tax
cuts border control and defense spending
I made big Promises to the American
people and unlike other presidents I
kept my promises I kept
the question is a Republican party
generally sold on Trump policies still
buying the Trump brand this is just two
minutes drama and too much problems is
this the most wounded Donald Trump has
been it certainly is the most wounded
Donald Trump has been last Tuesday could
not have been worse for him
after the speech Trump's daughter Ivanka
posted on Instagram that while she loves
her father she will not quote be
involved in politics the statement did
not mention her husband Jared Kushner
who for the two previous Trump campaigns
was a key political advisor Tony
yeah major a lot of those wins that the
former president was referring to other
Republicans are saying those are in deep
red districts or losses in places where
the races were close or expected to be
about the speech last night there's
things set and then there are things
revealed by not being brought up at all
when it comes to things that stand out
because of their absence what did you
notice
no mention of the former president's
two-year-long obsession with election
denialism or
his three Supreme Court confirmations
that upended abortion rights voters
remembered both Trump may want to gloss
over that part of his history but voters
Remembered in the midterms and they're
likely to remember in the future
you know major there are also a lot of
prominent Republicans who in public or
in private told the former president the
timing is not good here after we we had
setbacks in the midterms so why do you
think the former president decided to
make this announcement anyway and do it
now
within Trump's Inner Circle there are
two theories one Trump has convinced
himself that by announcing his candidacy
he will somehow Shield himself from
indictment either from the justice
department over alleged mishandling of
classified documents or authorities in
Fulton County Georgia investigating
electoral vote scheme that's not true
but Trump believes it the other theory
is by getting in early he might
intimidate or box out Challengers like
DeSantis youngin his former Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo were former vice
president Mike Pence but anyone watching
last night's speech
Tony will not be intimidated
yeah and the New York Post is Hometown
paper carpeted on page 26 Florida man
makes announcement that's the headline
major thank you very much